já de bordo
data estelar 21 de outubro de 2015 pedex
goiânia
mas se nós estivéssemos no texas terra
se eu estivesse falando aqui para todas
as pessoas do planeta neste momento ou
até de outros planetas quem sabe qual o
idioma eu deveria usar para me comunicar
com essa diversidade de cores cultural
show mas o mandarim a língua mais falada
do mundo ou a língua do momento o inglês
ou talvez a língua portuguesa minha
língua materna e deixar que cada um
resolve o seu problema de tradução no
século 21
o futuro chegou mas ainda não resolvemos
o problema da comunicação global estava
numa cidade turística no sul do brasil
em 2012 de uma conferência internacional
e lá no hotel um dos cientistas e
palestrantes da conferência tentava se
comunicar com o funcionário na recepção
do hotel
mas eles não conseguiram se entender
depois de algum tempo me aproximei e
propus ajuda
tudo o que ele queria era a senha do
wifi
vejam bem o cientista americano ph.d
depois nos tornamos amigos só sabia
falar inglês
o funcionário do hotel
estudou inglês a vida toda até porque
aqui no brasil faz parte da grade
curricular obrigatório e ainda assim não
foi possível estabelecer um diálogo a
verdade é que as línguas nacionais sejam
elas quais forem inglês mandarim em
português não foram feitas para serem
usadas por todos
não funciona seja pelas dificuldades
gramaticais fonéticas de vocabulário
além das barreiras políticas e
psicológicas que afetam tanto cada
indivíduo quanto à coletividade
aqui no brasil nós um povo culturalmente
aberto aos estrangeirismos há décadas
estudando a língua inglesa língua do
momento ouvindo músicas filmes e três
entra tudo na língua de chip não
conseguimos nos comunicar isso foi visto
na rio + 20 durante as negociações e na
copa do mundo aqui no brasil
quando eu digo não conseguimos nos
comunicar
eu não estou dizendo ser capaz de dizer
romântico em miami mas de estabelecer um
diálogo significativo com outra pessoa
saber capaz de transmitir as suas idéias
seus sentimentos
as nuances a mensagem por trás da
mensagem e capaz também de receber tudo
isso o nosso outro irmão que não fala a
mesma língua
existem é verdade dispositivos
aplicativos hoje que produz se propõe a
ajudar e auxiliar o ensino de outras
línguas ea tradução e são muito úteis
mas é preciso ser franco que na verdade
eles são apenas paliativos modernos e
elegantes charmosos mas são paliativos
eles não conseguem estabelecer a ponte
de comunicação comunicar a comunicação é
tornar comum é preciso que nós desejamos
desejamos isso a google empresa que
trabalha muito tempo um software de
tradução e que faz muito bem tem o seu
software de tradução que é muito usado
para para a produção textual é muito
válido apesar de não ser perfeito mas
ela não só aplicativo e se propõe a
fazer exatamente igual ao tradutor
universal
na oeste enterprise de star trek jornada
nas estrelas ou seja ele traduzia em
tempo real um diálogo entre duas pessoas
que não falam a mesma língua
dois cientistas da revista the economist
fizeram um teste com ele um teste
simples foram restaurante e tentavam
reservar uma mesa para quatro pessoas
bom o teste
infelizmente não foi um sucesso além de
eles não terem conseguido fazer essa
tradução falando inglês ea língua alvo
sendo alemão ainda criou uma série de
problemas que os colocaram na situação
embora sozinho ou seja gerou novos
problemas como disse o pesquisador da
área da indústria de tradução automática
é mais fácil fazer um carro um automóvel
honda sozinho do que um software de
tradução verbal oral funcionar a
contento
bom talvez por isso a população do oeste
enterprise ele estivesse junto um
tradutor humano para resolver esses
problemas mas a cada planeta visitado
centenas ou milhares de outros idiomas
ou tradutor universal não seria capaz de
resolver e nem aprender fluentemente o
klingon resolveria porque atendeu apenas
uma parte infinitesimal do problema e
isso acontece aqui também no nosso
planeta
centenas milhares de língua estão em
línguas estão em extinção ea cultura
delas junto bom precisamos entender o
que queriam se queremos implantar
dispositivos no futuro de recepção de
receptor de sons identificar a mensagem
recebida tradução automática e
deficiente e sintetizador de voz
seremos uma sociedade do futuro de
cyborgs traduzindo o idioma raso
robótico em preciso
queremos algo mais um diálogo
significativo e humanizado já teriam
dito que o dia com a tecnologia que deve
ser usada sempre a nosso favor
da humanidade ea ciência mas o dia que
ela se sobrepusesse a humanidade seria
um tênis uma geração de jotas e assim
também é com a comunicação
bom a verdade é que a ciência já nos
legou o projeto que resolve o problema
da comunicação global
esse projeto foi planejado testado
durante décadas envolvendo milhares de
pessoas aliás milhões de pessoas em
diversos países do mundo
atingir o seu objetivo comunicação rica
simples e eficiente inclusiva aprovado
pela unesco pela sociedade filosófica
americana e outras é sociedades
acadêmicas
o projeto que a ciência nos legou se
chama esperanto língua verbal basear em
16 regras gramaticais regulares sem
nenhuma exceção
cada letra representa apenas um único
som em casa só uma única letra a língua
fonética as raízes do idioma são
baseados nas principais línguas faladas
portanto é uma língua comum família pra
qualquer um ficar aprender esperando aí
cresce a cada dia no planeta todo mas
vocês vão ver isso na mídia tradicional
que é alimentada pela indústria do
idioma do momento e da tradução gera
receitas de bilhões de dólares
anualmente esperando consegue criar uma
rede de pessoas no mundo todo
capazes de se comunicar sem intérpretes
100 produtores de qualquer ordem
imagine você num congresso com cinco mil
pessoas de centenas de países diferentes
cada um falando uma língua materna
diferente mas naquele momento todos se
comunicam sem nenhum tradutor humano ou
automático
isso é incrível porque você conversa
qualquer
pessoa sem ter a idéia de onde ela é
isso também não importa o princípio
porque cada um é um universo rico
infinito que deve ser capaz de ter o
direito de se comunicar com qualquer
outro do planeta esperando ele é justo
porque ele não dá nenhum povo privilégio
de ter a sua língua obrigatória para os
demais e eu me pergunto por que insistir
nesse modelo onde uma coletividade
obriga as outras aprender a sua língua
percebam que você está sendo criado um
grande enorme mercado consumidor da
cultura alheia e não fomos consultados
se queríamos isso esperando não sendo de
nenhum povo é de todos para cada povo a
sua língua materna para todos os demais
o esperanto oportunidade a humanidade
tem única de criar um só povo quando o
identidade universalista fraternity está
derrubando várias fronteiras
nacionalismo sectarismo insistem nos
separar o idioma é um valor estratégico
que talvez não temos noção disso as
fronteiras foram criadas para separar os
povos
o idioma também é preciso então que
reconheçamos que a família humana é uma
só e a casa também é uma só a terra não
façamos como os europeus que durante
muitos séculos negligenciado os
algarismos arábicos em prol dos
organismos romanos porque o sistema mais
simples e eficiente lógico né de
prevalecer assim seria se
nascemos a lógica vulcana de esporte
estaremos pois o melhor aplicativo o
esperanto no melhor dispositivo já
inventado cérebro humano da onu